foreign
comes from Kelsey in Wyoming my husband
is a loyal Ramsey Show listener after I
tried to get him on board for years and
we are on our
Financial Journey towards home ownership
we are so close and I am making many
sacrifices but my husband won't make the
one huge sacrifice that would get us in
a home ASAP he has a work truck
that he can use for all driving and
we're still keeping his fun car she's
got fun in quotes oh boy that's got some
emotion uh wrapped around that one
whenever you go to the old fun car oh
boy the cost of the car includes paying
Insurance maintenance switching out
seasonal tires Etc
while it maybe gets driven once a month
boy maybe he's in all caps the tension
is building as I read this folks uh the
way the used car market is and the Kelly
Blue Book value we could excuse me we
would be able to finish funding our down
payment with the sale of this car he
will not entertain this idea our rent is
also being raised and current projection
have us taking another two years to save
up help please oh boy oh man wow layers
layers here's one thing I've learned
though you can't make anyone do anything
it's like so Kelsey you're either gonna
have to become really persuasive oh boy
um
because like you can't just
yeah what are you gonna do like make him
sell it like but but so so what do you
do what do you do I would get underneath
really like your goals what you guys
want and that's that that's the ideas
getting on the same page so I was gonna
say if you would have your down payment
saved up in six months let it go let it
go Kelsey Let It Go and just save up and
do the down payment but two years that
would frustrate me that would be hard
my rent's being raised and I'm like man
so I'm gonna so you know what I'm gonna
do I'm I okay so I'm all right if I'm
her
I'm not going to keep you know fighting
the whole sell your precious car okay so
I'm gonna go all right
I get it I'm not going to keep trying to
create more attention I want to try to
get you to sell your car I know you'll
love your car whatever whatever
but I don't want to wait two more years
our rent's going up
so if you won't sell the car what will
you do meet me in the middle if I let go
of a car yep what will you do will you
work another job that's what I do I I
would take the car off the table and
then he relaxes he takes a deep breath
and I know how dudes are wired he thinks
he gets a win there
and right when he starts to get
comfortable you go but
we gotta do something you gotta give me
something give me something man yeah and
he needs to know too like
for me if I was in that situation you
start to feel like he loves this car
more than our future don't think he's
valuable wow that's a little bit how it
feels though it feels like if we are if
if we are working this plan together we
know what we want we want to be in a
house financially it makes more sense to
be in a house than to have a rent raised
for two years you're choosing your thing
over like where we could be like she's
not asking to take the money from the
used car and go buy like or the car and
go buy purses with it right like 100
wait a second this is I'm so glad you
said this because we gotta unpack this I
agree with everything you said except
for the nuclear option there you went
nuclear and you can't but it feels like
yeah but you can't say that to him
because you're going to push him away
even further he's gonna then he's gonna
feel no look look we got a guy out in
the lobby shaking his head listen no and
the lady's gone she may not feel and she
and I'm not going to put that on couch
let's say that
you can't say you can't say it feels
like you want your disagree your kids
she feels that I'm not saying she does
Let's Pretend she does let's pretend
that the way I would that I could be
like man that would be really hard and
that would be really hard it would be
it'd be very frustrating I totally get
that if I'm feeling that I get that I
one thousand percent would say that to
Winston in a respectful way but I'm like
babe this is what matter
you're not being known in your marriage
Ken if you cannot communicate what
you're feeling say that what you're
feeling no you could say I'm feeling
frustrated and I know I came after you
I'm gonna tell you now we cannot have a
conversation like this
I don't think you could say that to the
guy because then you make him defensive
what I said was I agree that he needs to
make a sacrifice but if it's not that it
needs to be something else and she needs
to say I'm feeling frustrated and I'm
feeling like you aren't as committed to
getting in the house as as fast as I am
and I'm frustrated about a rent going up
and you so you know what I did come at
you in the car but I don't want there to
be tension between us but I'm asking you
you got to meet me in the middle you got
to come somewhere else that's what I'm
saying don't say it feels like you love
the car more than me that's horrible
thing to say okay let me say this number
one I agree with everything you said and
I think that's a great option but also
if I if she feels that way though if
Kelsey feels that way which I'm totally
putting this on Kelsey I think it is a I
think that is healthy if John zaloney
was sitting in here Dr annoying he would
say my because it because it triggers a
fear it trigger it like stuff oh it
triggers it triggers him all right and
it's not and it's not a difference
that's right and it's not a
disrespectful thing but if I don't have
the freedom to be able to communicate
that to myself
I said don't say that I gave you a much
nicer Hallmark healthy relationship man
no no no okay seriously in all seriously
do you really believe that if you say to
your husband you love this object that
he cares about more than you I could say
that doesn't trigger him here's what I
would say no here's what I would say I
would say man this is man hey man uh I
would this is how I communicated I would
just say I don't know I'm thinking off
the cuff here
um that for our family and what our
goals are in life that we could be there
so much sooner that's very different
than what you did I'm not done and
because you're not wanting it you're
holding on to something that can push us
forward and what and underneath that if
we're going a level deeper it feels like
it's choosing like gosh the future or
this thing and walk me through that let
me I want to hear from you
uh you know what you're seeing what what
is the value that this cars brings I
want to know that about you like I want
to know why this is this but this is
what's going on in me I think that is
that is marriage to me that's marriage
so I don't disagree with all of that
version that version was a little bit
like less nuclear than the whole it
feels like you love the car more than me
you have to communicate though because I
do think I can see that there's stuff
under that like it sucks listen I agree
with you I just you don't want to put
him on the defensive if you want him to
beat you in the middle and the way you
say it your tone is everything so you
can't go bicker no I don't think that
but for me to tell you hey here's here's
ultimately what I'm feeling and that in
it and and I'm fearful in that like help
me with that like let's talk through
that that's I would say I think it's
okay to say I don't feel like you are as
intentional and as excited about getting
in the house as I am I wouldn't say you
love something more than me that's all
I'm saying maybe not those words but it
could be the fear and if it's the fear
she needs to communicate it okay I love
it good stuff we're not marriage
counselors let's just throw that out